[Musique]
alors que la Villa la plus chère du
monde peine à trouver un propriétaire un
demi milliard d'euros des stars sont
parfois prêtes à dépenser une petite
fortune pour se loger et le dernier en
date c'est lui
cyano Ronaldo qui a tout simplement
décidé d'acheter la Villa la plus chère
du Portugal à 30 km de Lisbonne pour 21
millions d'euros la Villa fait plus de
2700 m² possède une énorme piscine et
s'étend sur pas moins de trois étages
mais avant de s'y installer la star du
ballon rond on va devoir patienter un
petit peu puisque les travaux devraient
se terminer en 2023
[Musique]
21 millions d'euros pour la Villa
Cristiano Ronaldo c'est la Villa la plus
chère du Portugal
c'est pas mal franchement la villa et la
villa est belle quelle est la plus
grosse folie que tu es fait au patrie
quant à la quantité d'animateur est-ce
que toi je suis arrivé sur la 5 et que
bernosconi m'a offert à l'époque une
Ferrari
[Musique]
c'était la 912 et je l'ai accepté t'as
bien fait pas longtemps parce que
je n'avais pas du tout du tout avec
l'image que j'avais et donc les gens
quand ils me voyaient au feu rouge avec
une Ferrari
c'est pas bien c'est pas bien pour vous
et donc c'est vrai que c'était pas bien
pour moi et donc je l'ai rendu
quand il est arrivé dans une chaîne on
lui offert une Ferrari une bouteille
d'occasion
[Applaudissements]
vous a offert des voitures
[Rires]
férié et je peux être extrêmement sévère
il faut faire
c'est pas beau c'est dégueulasse
merci
Gilles heureusement que tu es là
heureusement que tu es là c'est quoi la
plus grosse folique des fêtes toi ah
pareil moi voiture
c'est incroyable quand tu arrives dans
une chaîne on t'envoie une Ferrari c'est
beau tout pareil
je crois à peu près 20000 dans le monde
c'était rien ouais j'ai acheté une
Ferrari d'occasion hein bien sûr et je
me disais quand même quand je tourne
Ferrari on est on est 20.000 dans le
monde sur 6 milliards en avoir une pas
regardé très longtemps parce que c'est
n'importe quoi pourquoi 20000 en fait 2
millions en fait il se disent des
conneries
dans la rue j'en ai vu partout
j'adore les Twingo je vous jure que
j'adore c'est moi qui fait acheter les a
Twingo à Valérie Benaim non eh oui les
chéris
j'adore aussi
sur les voitures
pas pour toi non non
c'est bon là
en voiture j'ai fait j'ai tout eu non en
gros achat un gros appartement un gros
appartement des appartements mais comme
ça du jour au lendemain ah non mais non
pas du jour au lendemain et j'ai
réfléchis mais ce qui est drôle c'est
qu'à l'époque j'avais emmené mon
banquier et c'était vraiment très très
bel appartement et qui était très très
au dessus de mes moyens comme d'habitude
et d'être autour de je sais pas une
dizaine de millions d'euros je pense et
d'ailleurs il connaît cet appartement
c'est en fait ce qui était
semble
un prêt à la banque et que le banquier
donc c'est-à-dire pour ce bref je vienne
voir et il a eu cette phrase que
j'oublierai jamais il rentre dans
l'appartement et il dit on achète non
c'est pas vrai et on a acheté et depuis
le banquier dans quelle prison
c'est objectivement je n'aurais jamais
dû mais c'est pareil que ça parteventura
la mosaïque au sol ça faisait B C
c'était Benjamin Castaldi baisse ta
culotte
comme quoi Castaldi mais moi je l'aime
aussi
je l'aime pour ça c'est les montagnes
russes regardez non mais c'est vrai et
voilà il faudrait que ça monte un peu de
temps en temps quand même mais tu veux
que je te dise c'est quand tu es en bas
que tu es le meilleur
[Rires]